if you had to choose between True Blood
Daredevil or The Punisher
to do again oh to do again
I'm gonna guess yeah good Ryan you're
gonna guess too
I'm gonna say it was True Blood you're
wrong
I was gonna say that too yeah I I would
I would say I would say no
um partially because the the Marvel
series feel unfinished to me because we
got canceled when we thought we were
gonna have more so there is a part of me
that was like I had more to say about
Karen and and we I felt like I was in
the middle of that story whereas True
Blood you know again for all of its ups
and downs and and triumphs and flaws we
did get to wrap it up I knew that we
were wrapping it up I could say goodbye
to everyone I stole something from the
set you know I didn't get to steal
anything from our our Daredevil set and
I didn't get to say goodbye to the crew
because we all thought you thought we
were coming back
um so that's really what I I would want
back and I wouldn't have all of that
back obviously
um and The Punisher and Daredevil feel
kind of of one to me mostly because
the character really
lives and thrives in Daredevil but I
loved the work I got to do in Punisher
and also you know I played a 17 year old
um True Blood and you know that show was
like a soap opera you've grown up a
little bit yeah and I there I really
enjoyed as Karen playing someone my own
age
because at a certain point I was like
even you know even if three years have
passed over the seven years of True
Blood I am now a you know a 28 27 year
old woman playing a 20 year old and
having to keep alive a little bit of
that like innocence and and insecurity
everyone else is older and stronger and
wiser and you know that stuff and so to
go be Karen and be kind of like I've
lived and I've seen some [ __ ] and
own that a little more I think I as
Deborah needed to play someone more like
that after having been a kid for so long